[Music]
so I know that just because of the
things that we talk about here every
week when you say the word liberal that
a certain amount my audience is going to
go wait a minute does he mean classical
liberal or does he mean progressive or
leftist or saying you it's obvious to me
you're making that distinction but the
word liberal is not been so muddied that
yes some ways it's not even yet
worth the progressives who shut down the
Nickelodeon's in the turn of the
twentieth century
they're the ones who change the meaning
of the word they seized it sort of after
World War one and said oh no we're
liberals and people are like what are
you talking about you're not liberals
you want the state to control much of
the economy and and much of our lives
but they started to use that word and it
stuck and so once this once the New Deal
happens in the 1930s Franklin Roosevelt
becomes another Jesus figure and he
calls himself liberal and they people
call his movement liberal then it that
was it that was the moment the turning
point no this is all of course a
repudiation of classical liberalism
which is about the individual you know
having some autonomy or at least freedom
from the state and its power do you
think that people like us can win that
word back that's what I've been thinking
about a lot lately I like making this
argument for liberalism versus the left
I just don't think it's a liberal
movement okay and I know that I brought
a lot of people to it and have many
allies that are doing similar work are
you included but do you think it's
possible like the word liberal is now so
tainted that in a broader sense maybe we
can't build something around that word
not to say the ideas can't be used in
another way yeah so I'm not sure I want
to so I'm not a classical liberal and I
don't love classical liberalism I like
some of it but the the Puritan notion of
the repressed individual who never talks
about sex and only have sex to procreate
and who works all the time that's
actually at the center of classical
liberalism so if you read john locke and
you read the founding fathers this is
what they say you know we must regulate
ourselves so that the state doesn't have
to so it's a cultural Puritanism it's
good that they don't want to state
regulating us in those ways so I like
that like celebrites
but they say for that to happen for that
to be possible we must constantly police
ourselves so the cop becomes internal
the police the policeman is inside of us
so I don't love that yeah yeah yeah
that's interesting because I'd never
thought of it in that I know exactly
we're talking about but to me that was
more of just a sign of the times than
versus now because are we all policing
ourselves in our own way I mean every
day you get up and you don't do
everything that every whim that you want
to do at every turn the urge that you
want to so we're all sort of doing that
German by living right oh yeah sure it's
not I mean it's not it wasn't a sign of
the times they made this argument
I mean Locke and the founding fathers
the whole first chapter of my book
renegade history is on this I mean if
you think about its consistent right
they wanted the people or at least some
of the people many of the people to
control the country take it away from
the king and run it themselves and they
understood this thing that the Leninists
understood a century later which is that
oh to do that Jesus we got it like learn
a bunch of stuff and we've got to stop
you know going to the [ __ ] fights and
stop smoking cigars no really and stop
drinking most of all and because we got
a work to do we've got to run this
country democracy I say is puritanical
for that reason so it's interesting
because as you know you say you work
with learn liberty their classical
liberal organization they sent you to me
I just wanted what's makeup nobody I
want make a point of saying that's why
it's a beautiful thing that you're doing
with them because you just said I am NOT
a classical yeah where do you if you had
to give yourself a label I know you
don't want to get hung up on that pens
up but I sense a lot of classical
liberal stuff for you I sense some
libertarian stuff from you I said some
utility of the state from you what the
hell is that I don't know let's make up
a new word I don't know I mean I don't
know I I am I have sort of culturally I
guess I'm an artistic I suppose I I am
anti-authoritarian I'm anti-authority it
doesn't mean I want to demolish
Authority and remove Authority in fact I
like that there are some people in this
world who want to take charge because I
don't want to do that work right I don't
want to do that work yeah it's weird
right that there are some people who
just want to manage everything and like
take control and take care of everything
I don't want to determine who picks up
your garbage on Monday morning I mean
that's
fine I'm glad you want to do that I'd
rather play video games or whatever it
is right and so I don't know what that
is I mean it's a that's why I like a lot
of libertarianism you know obviously
because they want the state out of our
lives but a lot of libertarians are have
this classical idea of the
self-regulating individual they're right
at the middle of it and so I don't like
that at all because they're kind of not
fun either they're actually a lot of
libertarians remind me of the Socialists
that I grew up with they're very stodgy
and very kind of uptight and controlled
and not interested in the real world and
the pleasures in the real world all the
pleasure they get is from reading books
which I understand but there's more to
life than that yeah you know this past
week was or about a week ago was VidCon
which is where all these the youtubers
get together I didn't go but a lot of
the people that are sort of in my
youtube circles most of them are younger
than me were there and it seemed like
what I could gather was they were the
fun group but there's these people on
the left that are screaming about third
wave feminism and all this stuff and
then they're at a YouTube conference
it's not a lot of many people on the
traditional right but that's this new
group whatever this thing is of these
sort of half liberal libertarian mix
whatever that they're the fun group and
that's what's attracting people I think
that was probably a lot of what was in
the middle of gamergate which was that
there's these kids playing video games
who like looking at women with big boobs
and have that and enjoying it right and
that was about it I think for most of
them I would imagine right they like
shooting people right virtually yeah you
know and watching the heads explode
which you're not allowed to do by the
way that's another form of repression
that the Puritans and the Victorians
instituted we can't fight each other in
the streets at anarchic and disorderly
we have to let the state do all the
killing for us right we get the monopoly
on violence the state does so you can't
do that anymore so like boxing was
shunned for a long time all these things
you know and so I think I think video
games represent sort of a return of the
repressed to use Freud's term yeah you
know in that way because these kids are
doing stuff you're not allowed to do it
through these video games which is kill
and have sex or at least some kind of
sex be sexual in that way and it's fun
now we know that this didn't cause them
to go out and shoot people we know that
didn't cause them to go out and rape
people we know this from many many many
study they're great every study yeah
every study okay so we just know that
and so they were having fun doing the
stuff that you're not allowed to do or
even express you're not even allowed to
express those desires in this culture
right and then all of a sudden you have
these people coming in swooping in and
telling them that not only what they're
doing just their thoughts their feelings
are bad but that it's going to cause
another Sandy Hook and another mass rape
somewhere and that it's it's the cause
of the subjugation of women well it
doesn't make sense to these kids and I
imagine and it's like we were just
having fun in our mom's basement yeah we
by the way we have zero institutional
power in this country right nothing
nothing and you're telling us suddenly
we are the most powerful people in the
world now and by the way I'm speaking
for them now why what here's what's so
amazing to me that a gamer gat hat for
you yeah here's what's so amazing
amazing why are feminists or went or
anywise anyone so concerned about what
those people think like that's what it
becomes important in a lot of feminist
discourse is what we think what men
think well that all that does is sort of
rien scribe the patriarchy right what we
think what we do is what's important
right men do and think is what's
important well how about just say I'm
going to do what I want to do and many
feminists by the way have done this
there's a different strain of feminism
that I love which has been called
sex-positive feminism or independent
feminism but that's sort of where the
Christina Hoff Sommers I hope she
doesn't book that one intersect but she
but more just like let them do their
thing
maybe yeah so I had a guest on my show
her name's Anna Arrowsmith she's a she
was a feminist in and she hated
pornography she thought it you know
degraded women and then she was walking
down the street in Soho in London which
is the red-light district basically in
London thinking and watching all these
shops full of these you know video
videos with sex all over it she was
turned on by it and she thought oh wait
a minute I'm turned off but yeah but I
don't like that so you know I'm going to
do I'm going to make my own porn and so
she started making your own porn she
became the biggest female pornographer
and
world and did it on our own terms and
it's all hardcore there's nothing she
doesn't hold any held anything back she
just makes it nicer looking and the men
are better looking etcetera and that's
it to me that's feminism do it on your
own make your own world right instead of
worrying constantly about what I want
and what I think yeah how unhealthy do
you think just having to talk about
politics all the time is I don't mean
what we're doing right right so I don't
mean for the people that have these
conversations about ideas and that but I
mean for the average person that all day
long now because of social media is
harping about every little decision that
happens in the government and that I try
'kz me as it's becoming it's starting to
like really rock people's minds or
something like I would argue that a good
government is one that's small enough
that you wouldn't have to talk about it
all the time
now there's probably good
counter-argument to that but the idea
that people are all day worried about
this seems like a real problem well so
when you say people you know I mean yeah
how many people are we talking about
again I think it's right it's hard to
gauge is the I think it's a lot of
people talking to each other right I
think it's a pretty small world that we
inhabit or that we observe right I think
the I think most of all what is it
twenty five percent of Americans are on
Twitter okay so that's a quarter it's a
pretty big chunk but of those how many
just read with Katy Perry's feed right I
mean I think that those who do polish
can be more bizarrely political though
because doing stuff with Hillary so okay
yeah but let's say you know what's
called political Twitter yeah I don't
know but how many people are there right
and how many people they're just you
know just check in on the Democratic
Party's latest you know issue
announcements right I think it's a
pretty small world I'm not too worried
about the population in general but I do
think that the world that you and I have
chosen to live in is pretty
uncomfortable and I'd say since the
election in particular is nearly
intolerable so I used to be a Twitter
addict and then since the election it's
actually been really hard it's not been
fun to go on Twitter it really almost
never is fun it almost always makes me
sad or angry and so I watch it less you
know and I don't know I think that maybe
the next phase we're going to go through
the Twitter will become something else
or there'll be alternative
to it and you know it's just people
talking the thing is to just keep going
and not I know it's hard but to not let
the eggs with the five followers get to
you they get to me but we just have to
keep going if we want to do this you
know
what about the amount of time that we're
spending on this that I think that's
really what I meant they're not just not
just the griping but the amount of time
people are worried about these things
like your broader people yeah I mean
well the thing that I don't like is the
policing that goes on it's a constant
policing right you said this and that
you shouldn't say that you shouldn't
think this you shouldn't feel this you
need to check yourself you need to watch
yourself it's all it's a totalitarian
language which again by the way comes
out of the Frankfurt School it does
which you know their argument was that
language is this tool of the oppressor
against the oppressed and so we need to
we need to recapture the language and
make it our own to bring about
revolution that was the Frankfurt School
it's it's a totalitarian impulse it's a
totalitarian politics if it's no fun to
be around and I think that's the thing
people are just they're repudiating it
sort of tacitly in that they are they're
watching their video they're playing
video games instead they're watching
television instead they're not engaging
in this discourse you and I are
masochists because we do it most people
are not masochist in that way so that's
to me the cause for hope yeah it's so
funny because I enjoy 90% of it there is
that 10% of just you know when people
are maliciously misquoting me or writing
things that are blatantly not true the
rest of the interaction I can basically
deal with and I do love the battle of
ideas but believe me I hear you there's
there's like an unspoken thing that we
can do here that I can't quite frank
quantify in words so I'm curious so all
this being said you have an interesting
myth you know mix-match of politics and
culture and all that stuff is there
anyone in politics right now that you
like that you go this guy kind of gets
it no don't say meaning like electoral
politics
yeah just anyone right now or well now
who in the public space in general like
they're like a couple is there anyone in
electoral politics there's no one yeah I
mean in fact I thought Trump was
interesting in those ways he was at
least raising these questions for the
first time I mean I can't stand most of
what he's for in terms of policy but he
was raising these questions for the
first time so I got to talk about them
that was great thank you for the
opportunity now leave office and just
please don't do anything when office is
the best thing but no in Elektra
politics there's no one because they are
part of the machine or at least they
want to be part of the machine so being
part of the machine means making
yourself a cog right uninteresting in
what you know uninteresting to me there
are very few cultural radicals left
there are a few sort of sex radicals
there's like three you know I find them
interesting you know people who say yeah
we should talk about sex we should be
able to express our desires openly it's
better sex is a good thing sex is not a
bad they almost don't exist the 60s had
that the new left and the counterculture
had some people there who are quite
interesting in that way but they're gone
and it's very sad yeah it's interesting
there's this writer I forget Lee writes
for even but I don't you saw this thing
where he took a screen capture of his
screen and one of his tabs had hentai
mourn on it which I guess is it's like
on the foreigners arrows I'm like some
cartoon porn but he's a lefty so all
these people on this all right you know
these midweek so anything goes over here
they were all attacking him and I was
like do you guys not see the irony and
hey you're doing here like it wasn't
illegal what he was doing it was some
odd thing you know well I mean I thought
you guys are the free being you know
alrighty
I mean a lot of the left I would imagine
is would attack him too I mean they have
in the past right now that's you know
that's the objectification of women so
we can't have that right
yeah no it's it's it's not fun but so in
terms of yeah no I guess I I guess it
sort of my mission to kind of bring back
that kind of and it is left-wing here's
here's part of my politics suits like
that sort of left cultural radicalism
back into political discourse which is
just a exist
really so when you say left cultural or
Ataman radicalism you actually do mean
freedom mmm-hmm in that context it
doesn't sound like something that
modern left now but that's what your
fine you're talking about real great art
you're talking about great comedy all of
those things yeah I'm talking about
Lenny Bruce yeah
and Richard Pryor right you talk about
stand-up comics yeah those are my heroes
those are my original heroes Richard
Pryor is my original hero because he did
that he just said he said well you're
not supposed to say he said what you're
not supposed to say that's what great
comedy is it makes us laugh and that's
what makes them so brilliant you know
and yeah I don't know if that's lost but
it's certainly being challenged oh it's
being it's just being squeezed Lenny
Bruce yeah I went to prison yeah for
that okay and so do we want to return to
that do we want to put comedians in jail
for saying things you're not supposed to
say not doing things you're not supposed
to do saying things you're not supposed
to think giving voice to the taboo
giving voice to the forbidden that's
what they do
shouldn't we have that imagine what
would be happening if George Carlin who
would be 80 years old right now was
still trying to go to college campuses
they'd be screaming about this old white
man who is saying all of these things
this is a massive problem that's why by
the way I was so dispirited I guess by
Bill Maher's apology because everyone
knows he's not racist so I'm not saying
that I'm going to sit here and want to
use that word if it bothers people of
course speech has consequences I
understand that but the apology struck
me as man a comedian who's been the hero
of the left has to now bow to them this
strikes me as a major problem okay are
you ready to get into more trouble Dave
let's go okay so [ __ ] is arguably the
most important word in American history
if we don't use that word we're not
serious about understanding American
history we're not serious about
understanding that this culture you can
be an anti-racist or a racist or
anything but if you don't talk about
that word and use that word the way it's
been used in history not to hurt people
not as an epithet but to simply refer to
it right we can't do that
we're not grown-ups here we're not being
serious about ideas about history about
our culture about America we can't
understand it and that's really what it
is it's avoiding these ideas
rather than hitting them head-on people
talk about slavery as if they know
anything I don't know anything about
slavery they just know that it was wrong
and there was whippings all day long it
was nothing but rape and torture having
never read a thing about the history of
slavery it's the same thing right it's
it's when you moralize write about ideas
that is anti-intellectual that is saying
oh this thing is outside the realm of
discourse this is outside the realm of
inquiry it's anti intellectual and it's
lazy and I would say it leads to things
that are worse it leads to things like
Donald Trump because you are repressing
again these ideas and there are people
who just won't be repressed and they're
going to come back and they're going to
say yeah you're playing identity
politics you're saying there's blackness
and whiteness and you're black and I'm
white well okay fine now I'm going to
say I'm about whiteness and being white
so that's the problem there I mean it's
it's it's a very bad thing to avoid we
have to use these words yeah it's so
interesting because I've heard people
make that argument I saw my friend
Michael Shermer make that argument about
that you're just creating an identity
politics of white people and I saw him
get into a fight with some leftist
professor on Twitter and I by the way I
I offered her an opportunity to come
here and defend her ideas she declined
but I so obviously see that but it also
leads to all sorts of other cultural rot
because by taking the word out of Huck
Finn well now you well that was a book
that's it's not only stood the test of
time but now you're altering the
original meaning not to mention that
Huck Finn was anti-racist look yeah
which as Bill Maher has been anti places
but the point needs to be made that if
it were racist we still have to use the
word right not as an epithet again not
the way the racists use the word but we
have to be able to talk about racism
we're not here's that here's the
terrible irony is that by not being
allowed to use that word we are not
allowed to talk about racism we're not
allowed to study it think about it
ticket seriously right it's like in
Germany you're not allowed to basically
talk about Nazism unless you just sort
of moralize it really quickly wouldn't
you rather as a Jew or an anti-nazi or
any would you rather a study it really
hard really closely if you don't want to
return to that
yeah well it's why I mean that's a free
speech guys why I'm completely against
the laws that you know criminalized
Holocaust denial because they're not
going to stop denying it they're just
going to go into their secret little
places and I'd rather have all there are
more real Nazis in Germany than than in
the United States what we are allowed to
talk about it yeah yeah but okay so you
just so you said the word now I know
certainly people talk angry though
because I have not said the word huh
while sitting here with you like the
second you know that there's a certain
cost there you know you mean like yeah
and it just has you just sort of shifted
past that well if not you get your
you've made your sort of philosophical
point now it's just yeah so just I would
just say listen to what I say after the
word because I very clearly put forward
why we should use that word and I'm
pretty sure what I said was anti-racist
yes anti-racist that anti racism
requires using the word [ __ ] and
that's why all this has been flipped so
then at Evergreen State to bring us back
to 40 minutes ago at Evergreen State you
have a professor Brett Weinstein who was
being anti-racist and now he is smeared
a racist so I guess that's what it is
when you don't deal with the truth
honestly you end up having to destroy
anyone who even gets close to it yeah
yeah yeah evergreen is um not a good
look I would say you know it's I don't
know if you want to go into this too
much but you know a lot of a lot that's
not said about what what causes this
craziness on campuses which is that you
know there's a monopoly that no one
talks about no one's even aware of this
in fact I wasn't even aware of it until
recently the the Department of Education
and the federal government authorizes
accreditation agencies accreditation
agencies of credit colleges and
universities and they have all these
rules it's not you can't just become a
college you have to have all these
things in place for them to accredit you
without accreditation the world doesn't
take you seriously employers don't take
you seriously right that credentialing
is crucial to this okay it's the federal
government at the head of this whole
thing of the
monopoly that they have right then on
top of that there's another monopoly
within it which is tenure the tenure
system right so after seven years if
you're lucky and you're good and you
follow the rules and you say the right
things you get tenure and you're there
forever
now who do you think you're going to
hire once you have tenure someone who is
who's contrary to your ideas or someone
who might agree with you someone who
makes you look good or someone who
challenges you hence we have this
uniformity of opinion in academia which
is supported defended bolstered by this
federal government state and force
monopoly no one knows this that's what's
going on here
third thing last thing you add to this
this system of affirmative action okay
which brings people onto campus who
according to the rules of affirmative
action have less training in academic
work than other kids so when they get
there of course it's going to be more
difficult for them to do the academic
work also it has been stated the purpose
of diversity and affirmative action is
to have these people represent their
race right and so imagine how crazy that
would make you feel in a classroom when
you're like one black kid or one
whatever kid or two black kids out of 30
and everybody knows why you're there and
you're supposed to represent your race
and people are wondering assuming that
you don't have the credentials that they
do that would make me crazy too and so I
almost everything that's been said in
the race discourse on campuses over the
last three years have been to me
fraudulent or hysterical and much of it
has been totalitarian by the way but I
think there is something at the bottom
of it that's legitimate there's a
legitimate grievance that
african-american students have on
colleges that's not addressed the tools
they have to talk about this are only
Martin Luther King and Rosa Parks and
Malcolm X and you know Bull Connor and
oppression and slavery so that's the way
that's that's the way they talk about it
and that's that's unfortunate and that's
the fault of their professors we need to
give them language we will talk about
what's really going on which is not good
it's not fun for the
yeah it's hard I absolutely get that it
could feel oppressive really that word
is the word I would use if I were them
but it's not the oppression they're
talking about there is no physical
threat to them there never has been
right there but there ya go interesting
yeah I referenced my interview Jason
Whitlock earlier but he said something
to that effect that basically the
oppression is different now and you have
to then change tactics you can't be
doing fighting the way that say Jesse
Jackson or a al Sharpton is using the
language of the old thing when there's a
whole different system in play right
right where you could get more natural
allies yeah and I'm only talking about
academia okay I'm not talking about
being a 19 year old in Ferguson Missouri
that's a different ballgame entirely I'm
talking about academia I know that world
very well those are the rules of the
world and that's what happens to these
black kids they're plucked out of these
neighborhoods put in these classrooms
and said oh go ahead represent your race
we're going to pay you to do that well
that's going to make you crazy so that's
a different it's what I call liberal or
racial liberalism it's a this idea of
the representative race and the idea
that with it we will give them the
chance to prove themselves that they can
be just like us
so there's an assimilationist impulse in
there too or an assimilationist
expectation we're going to show the
world that these black people can be
just like us which by the way is kind of
white supremacist in a way right because
they're saying well our world of course
is the best one Harvard of course is the
best place to be that's incredibly
elitist and superior and probably white
supremacist because Harvard of course is
historically have very white institution
yeah so just let people do what they
want to do we don't have to expect them
to go to Harvard alright well I suspect
we're going to do this again but I want
to ask you one final thing and I think
it's sort of been a through-line to what
you're talking about
I sense sort of like an alternate so
that's sort of a world weariness view
and then also like a total sense of
opportunity do you think these things
are in like 50/50 with you because I
have a lot of that too I am definitely
world.we I worry about the state of the
world what is going to happen to the
Western world and society and all these
trends that I talked about that I think
are
so dangerous and yet I could never do
this if I didn't have optimism care
about the ideas so I sense that
constantly about how where are your
percentages where do you and all that to
get out of bed and do what you do so
people are wealthier than ever before
there is less poverty in the world than
ever before
and so I'm very optimistic about that
going forward I constantly worry about
war I do I mean you know world war two
was not that long ago Vietnam wasn't
that long ago millions of people died in
that war that could happen literally at
any minute you know thinking about the
Middle East and these new coalition's
that are forming right now we have the
Saudi the Sunni side with the Saudis and
the US and Israel against the Shia side
with Iran and Syria and Russia and if
turkey makes its decision to go with the
with Toshiya which is very well might
because the Kurds then look what we have
there we have two huge military
alliances potentially fighting each
other that's terrifying to me so I'm
always worried about war I always will
be so long as there are militaries and
there probably will be but so I'm split
I don't know if the same you know what
I'm okay with ending a show on that
order I'd say that's the difference
between this show and most other shows
as long as you're okay ending that way
very okay all right very good well for
more Abadis check him out on the Twitter
although he's not on the Twitter that
much but he'll jump on for you it's at
Thaddeus Russell and thanks for watching
we'll do it again next week
[Music]
you
[Music]